foreign
did you know that cyber crime is
predicted to cause the world 10.5
trillion dollars annually by 2025. this
tracking figure highlights the growing
importance of cyber security in an
increasingly digital world so hey
everyone welcome back to another video
by simply learn in this video we will
dive into the essential skills that
every cyber security expert should
possess to protect themselves and their
organizations from cyber threats now
before moving forward let me ask you a
quick question which of the following is
an example of common Cyber attack
a fishing B option is physical intuition
option C is natural disaster and option
D is traffic condition
now you can pause this video and answer
in the comment section
cyber security is the practice of
protecting computer systems networks and
sensitive information from unauthorized
access in today's interconnected world
with data is being shared online the
need for lower cyber security measures
is essential
cyber attacks can come in many forms
including phishing scams malware
ransomware and many more and the
consequences can be severe from
Financial loss to reputation damage and
even legal consequences the impact of
cyber attacks can be devastating cyber
security spending is projected to reach
270 billions by 2026 as companies invest
in more advanced security Technologies
to combat cyber threats now to protect
against these threats it's crucial for
individuals and organizations to have a
strong understanding of cyber security
Concepts and skills so let's take a
closer look at some of the essential
skills that every cyber security expert
should possess but before that let me
take you through the advanced executive
program in cyber security this Advanced
executive program by simplylearn aims to
enhance your Knowledge and Skills in
various aspects of cyber security such
as defensive cyber security application
security malware analysis and ethical
hacking this program is a collaboration
between triple it Bangalore and npci and
it will provide you with the
comprehensive understanding of the cyber
security industry including identifying
opportunities for disruptions by taking
this course you will be equipped with
the necessary skills to excel in the
field of cyber security now let's begin
with our first skill knowledge of
computer networks and system
administration now what is computer
networks and system administration
computer networks are like a big digital
spider web that connects computers and
other devices together so that they can
communicate with each other think of it
like a group of friends passing notes
back and forth in the class the notes of
the information being shared and the
network is the systems that enables them
to do so a cyber security expert should
have a deep understanding of network
security Concepts and techniques such as
firewalls inclusion detection and
prevention systems and vpns they should
also have experience in implementing and
maintaining these security measures to
ensure that networks remain secure and
protected then system administration on
the other hand it is like being the
teacher who manages the classroom in
context of computer network system
administrators are responsible for
setting up maintaining and
troubleshooting networks so that it runs
smoothly and securely
this can involve tasks like installing
software updates configuring security
settings and monitoring the networker
potential issues system administration
is important for cyber security because
it involves managing and maintaining the
security of computer systems and
networks effective system administration
practices help to ensure that systems
and networks are secure from various
types of cyber threats now if you want
to gain these skills and some other
skills related to cyber security then
you can check out Caltech cyber security
bootcamp by simply loan the Caltech
cyber security bootcamp is a training
program that focuses on developing your
skills and knowledge in defensive and
offensive cyber security digital
forensics penetration testing
infrastructure design and other related
areas course curriculum labs and
assisted practices are designed to
provide you with exposure to various
in-demand cyber security tools by taking
this boot camp you will be able to
enhance your expertise and gain valuable
insights into the cyber security
industry next is familiarity with
operating system and software
one of the primary reasons why the
operating system is important for cyber
security is that it provides a layer of
protection between the computer hardware
and the various applications that run on
it the operating system implements
security measures such as Access Control
user authentication and data encryption
to protect against unauthorized access
and data theft operating system also
provides a framework for implementing
security updates and patches that
address vulnerabilities and protect
against malware and other type of cyber
threats timely installation of security
updates can help prevent cyber attacks
and data breaches the next skill is
knowledge of cryptography cryptography
is the practice of keeping information
secure by transforming it into a secret
code that can only be deciphered by
those who have the key to unlock it in
this information is secured using
encryption and decryption techniques a
cyber security expert should have a
strong understanding of cryptographic
concept including symmetric and
asymmetric encryption digital signatures
and hashing they should also be familiar
with different encryption algorithms and
how they can be used protect sensitive
data the next skill on the list is
incident response planning incident
response is the process of responding to
and managing a cyber security incident a
cyber security expert should be familiar
with incident response procedures and
have experience in handling different
types of incidents such as malware
infections and data breaches they should
also have a strong communication skills
to coordinate with other members of the
incident response team and manage the
incident effectively next up we have is
cloud security Cloud security refers to
the set of policies Technologies and
controls used to protect cloud-based
systems and data from unauthorized
access or damage cloud computing is
rapidly growing technology that enables
users to access and store data over the
internet instead on local computers or
servers
Cloud security is crucial for cyber
security because it helps to ensure the
confidentiality integrity and
availability of cloud-based systems and
data
as more organizations move their
operations to the cloud the risk of
cyber attacks increases making it
essential to implement robust Cloud
security measures
the next skill we have is risk
assessment risk assessment is a process
of identifying and evaluating potential
risks and threats that may affect an
organization assets or objectives
it involves accessing the likelihood and
potential impact of risk and crypto
security it involves accessing the
likelihood and potential impact of risk
security and then developing strategies
to manage this in the context of cyber
security risk assessment is a crucial
component of an organization overall
security strategy it helps organizations
to identify potential vulnerabilities
and threats to their computer systems
this information can then be used to
develop appropriate security measures
policies and procedures to reduce the
risk of successful attack in conclusion
cyber security is an ever-evolving field
that requires range of specialization
skills and knowledge cyber Security
Experts must be well versed in the
latest Technologies threats and defenses
as well as for the strong analytical and
problem solving skills whether working
in a private or public sector cyber
Security Experts play a vital role in
safeguarding sensitive information
systems and infrastructure from cyber
attacks alright guys with that we have
come to the end of this video If you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up I hope it will help you all thanks
for watching stay safe
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here